do you think the president and his
posture and his policies are
strengthening and making the American
economy more resilient are you concerned
about sort of the tenor of things at
this present moment I mean we are in a
trade war with China populism is fierce
does that concern you
having the institutional knowledge that
you have I would say gravely yeah you
know no no country can be stronger than
its political system you know no economy
can be stronger than its political
system and the political system in the
United States today is has lost that
capacity to govern and lost the core
requirements not just to make people
confident in the fairness of the system
but to find room for compromise on the
tough challenges we face in that context
and it's not something we can survive
indefinitely you know we're a strong
country a lot of underlying resilience
lots of good things happening American
economy today but we can't withstand the
effects of a prolonged period of a
broken of a system that's broken this
dysfunctional